and he has done it before he did win two
in a row against Prague to make that
comeback in each other think now yeah I
mean chances maybe will be slim but he
just has to keep the tension he has to
keep believing and he has to hope that
Magnus Carlton falls into the same trap
that Prague did a couple of days ago of
playing passively uh Magnus though he's
extremely experienced in these
situations when he only needs a draw and
he's gone back to his favorite opening
repertoire it's the Sicilian Defense and
this is a very trendy variation in
something very similar we saw a huge
Clash last season when Magnus sacrificed
his queen against Gary and won a
beautiful game so um yeah here we see
Gary just stepping forward with the pawn
he's already castled and rearranged his
pieces on the first rank white now he's
getting ready to step forward in the
center
so this is still quite well known stuff
I believe yep and we will see white gain
space in the center but black now will
strike back
there we go we see a Trader pawns and
knocking down the middle of the board if
white steps forward now we could see
something reminiscent of the first game
of the day with anishagiri playing
almost a French defense type structure
but of course white isn't obliged to
step forward and commit uh White could
stay a bit more flexible yeah and I have
to say pushing the pawn forward though
is the most natural and the most popular
move and I suspect that Anish will play
like that another alternative is just
simply to develop the Knight on B1 move
it to C3 and Anish well he goes for the
most natural looking move and now Magnus
Castle is the king
and again Anish has many options he can
develop the night as he's done another
option was just to actually pick up the
pawn in front of the king and move it
one square just to control the Circuit
of the Knight sitting on G6 yeah so
although this game started as a Sicilian
Defense it's essentially transposed into
the French defense at least the pawn
structure in the middle of the board is
blocked just like it was in the first
game and that's where the players will
be using pattern recognition remember
Magnus used the French defense in game
one and this Pawn structure arises from
the French Advance time and time again
so here it's all about whether black can
break out black needs to fight against
White Center sooner rather than later
otherwise black pieces are just very
cramped black is just stuck on his first
two or three racks at the moment while
White's Knights are coming forward white
will be able to bring Bishops forward
pawns forward
something like this in order to fight
back and I do like the opening Choice by
Gary I've got to say he's achieved
everything he could hope to achieve
against Magnus he's got all the pieces
on the board there's only been a trade
of one set of Pawns and a lot of tension
uh big questions for the Norwegian to
answer yeah definitely and I'm seeing an
interesting battle between what has
actually been played and the computer's
top recommendation so what has actually
been played is like black has often felt
very uncomfortable and just lashed out
just picked up the F Pawn and challenged
White's Pawn Center but the computer
isn't necessarily a fan of this I
approach and it kind of like no you're
committing things too early and instead
actually recommends that Magnus should
actually
just to play the Knight to H4 and just
say let's trade off some pieces but uh
hardly anyone has ever played like this
oh wow yeah I mean it's not an obvious
move to see because you've already moved
this Knight twice as black uh to get it
to this Square it looks like it's a
decent defensive square and it's a move
for it for a third time just to trade
off for the opponent's night
um yeah it's not maybe intuitive however
if you think logically with this Pawn
structure black is a bit cramped these
two pawns are further back than the two
white Pawns in the center therefore
you're cramped and you should be aiming
to exchange pieces that's the logic if
you have less space swap off pieces if
you have more space keep points keep
pieces on the board but hey he doesn't
go for either of those two ideas the
more I look at it the more I think he
should have done he should have taken
this opportunity to trade off because
after this bishop move now the other
idea that you mentioned Ivanka might
come into effect white could just step a
pawn forward and now this Knight is
never going anywhere into the white half
especially it's it's two squares are
controlled and giri does find that move
not only have you controlled the Black
Knight but you're getting ready to play
the most trendy idea in modern chess
you're getting ready to push Harry the
H1 forward and there's a target for that
pawn this Black Knight if it's kicked it
doesn't have any Escape squares apart
from in the corner and I don't think you
ever want to put the Black Knight in the
corner of the board yeah
I would take a special type of person to
voluntarily put that night there
Knight's on h8 you've got to hate oh
very good David
um yeah um I have to say the opening
tree is telling me that Black's most
popular move is actually to break open
the blacks the white porn Santa with F6
another idea is actually just to develop
the queen now he does it and now he does
it yeah yeah I think he had to before it
was too late before he got steamrollered
by the white Pawn coming forward uh so
he had to put pressure on White Center
that's good chess wisdom again and uh
okay after a Trader pawns I was
expecting the black Bishop maybe to
capture just to put some pressure on
white Central Pawn but Magna says no
he's going to take with the rook and he
might be lining up for something that we
call a thematic exchange sacrifice in
chess if white gives uh enough time for
example pushes a pawn then sooner or
later Magnus could consider giving up
his Rook for a night I'm not sure
whether you want to rush that now but it
is on the radar the whole idea is yes
you've given up a rook for night but you
win White's Central Pawn and uh long
term black has two Pawns in the center
which could start marching down the
board here I still feel that white is
active enough to have the advantage on
material your one point up but uh watch
out for that sacrifice later in the game
can tell you David no one I mean they've
only had been three games in database
and not one person had taken that porn
with a rook everyone else has had played
the most natural move which is Bishop
takes
and uh yeah you can see the the bar is
maybe not in favor of this whole choice
yeah
I I really like White's position I've
got to say I've played these positions
my whole career from the white side the
reason I like white is because this is a
weakness it's a backward Pawn
if you're careful it will never ever
step forward and if it doesn't step
forward then it's a clear Target but
also the square in front of it we
mentioned this is potential Outpost for
white Knights if you can eliminate the
two black knights if you can somehow
push these guys back or trade them off
perhaps for white Bishops then later on
white tonight has a perfect home in the
center of the board where it will
control everything so Magnus is the one
playing dynamically long-term Black's
position is riddled with weaknesses and
uh black will play dynamically in a
fashion that we mentioned either by
sacrificing on the Square or by maybe
lining up with his Queen along the f
file he needs to play for the attack
white has an isolated Thorn but it's a
very nice pull in controlling a lot of
squares right now so I'm expecting Gary
to bring his Bishop out to try and
centralize all his pieces uh another
move I would rush to play would be to
put my Bishop to defend this really
loose piece on F3 and from there you
slowly start to build up it's just about
containing blacks activity yeah
I agree David and I've also played this
type of position and I have really hated
it on the black side because primarily
it's all to do with that light Square
Bishop that you mentioned you know it's
such a bad piece and Anish he seems to
be in a very direct mood today and he's
like okay I'm gonna attack The Rook Rook
takes a step back and now we see a trade
of Bishops so nisha's just saying well
I'm going to just make those trades and
make sure that those dark squares around
the center are timely weak for you
Magnus yep and Gary's idea makes a lot
of sense it did cost a bit of time but
he's traded off White's potentially
worst Bishop White's dark Square Bishop
didn't have a safe home didn't have a
active post so he's traded off that
piece for black starts going Bishop
which covers that Outpost that we
mentioned on E5 so now if you compare
the remaining pieces on the board white
slight squared Bishop good piece
controls a lot of squares and black
slight Square Bishop a bad piece
um the nightmare scenario for black year
would be to let to be left in a good
night versus bad Bishop scenario so if
Black's Knights disappeared black would
just be left with that horrible Bishop
stuck defending its own pawns unable to
get active and okay Magnus dancing
around with his Knights meanwhile is he
in a little bit of trouble in this game
Magnus positionally strategically he's
yeah in a lot of trouble but he's active
enough for now to compensate for that so
the problem for Gary is taking advantage
of this uh of this situation it's very
much long term it will need a lot of
accurate moves it will need nerves of
Steel to control this yeah 20 30 moves
and only then take advantage later I do
feel that magnus's magnus's activity is
enough to kind of be slightly worse and
this pressure that Magnus has against
White's D4 Pawn is enough just to tie
anisha's Rooks down and Magnus just
making and improving move giving a safe
Square to the king
Gary while he's playing by the textbook
centralizing his work yeah
he is uh unbeaten so far in the
tournament uh Magnus crossing the niche
gear will have to change that if he's
gonna win the match today Magnus
Carlson's uh tour rating right now is 28
to 91 and his performance rating is only
3015 in this tournament only
not quite God yet
but that's incredible over 3 000 in
performance rating with
the top players in the world incredible
it's not as if he's just racking up wins
against a bunch of bunnies he's
literally competing against the top
rapid players the top speed players in
the world and so far he's made it look
very simple I mean it could have been
more even Magnus has led a few uh
half-point slip here and there by a
couple of careless moves
and uh yeah he's looking very composed
very calm he's doing all the right
things he just knows what squares to put
the pieces on and whilst Anish is
considering how he's going to try to
maximize his position well we did ask
today that our viewers share with us
their favorite chess pictures and Robert
Dalton says that shows us one there's a
pawn starting at the bottom of the board
ambition
we love the pawns yeah we do definitely
like that piece yeah some nice pictures
you guys thank you so much for sharing
and keep them coming right now it's
Magnus Carlson thinking he's digging the
music as well we're gonna go to San
Francisco where all the action is
happening today Tony are you guys having
fun
we were having so much fun because it
looks like Magnus for the first time
might be in a bit of trouble today but
can Anish actually crack this position
or not we'll find out he's got to give
it all he's got because otherwise it's
much over uh and for all the just
discussions going on in our mix Zone
we've got a special guest with us it's a
local chess Enthusiast and we've got
Drew with us joining hey Drew how are
you doing hi there how's it going well
as you can see it's quite a tense day
here are you enjoying the chess yeah
it's been it's been a lot of fun it's
really great to see see all these
Personalities in person for the first
time I've just got back to chess a
couple years ago and already I'm I'm
Magnus has been in the same room as me
so it's just it's super exciting who's
your favorite chess player
um um I'm gonna go with uh
uh oh that's a that's actually I was not
ready for that but let's go with uh
um I was just
um talking about uh grishek recently and
he's he's uh he's a super entertaining
player
um and so yeah he's probably I'll I'll
put grishek down for now very
interesting I was thinking if we're
gonna go with Wesley considering he is
the local hero right now playing inside
in that room right here oh yeah you know
Wesley's Wesley's great and it's super
exciting super exciting that we we get
to have we get to have local local uh
Talent here in the tournament and uh
it's it's a definitely exciting chess
chess here as well so 100 and I have to
ask you I mean there are so many strong
chess players from the Bay Area you've
got Sam Shanklin that's Christopher you
Daniel Nardi but there's also a big
casual chest scene here oh tell us a
little bit about that yeah uh we've
actually started up uh this summer a few
of us have been playing I've been
playing a lot of uh a park chess and and
playing for a couple hours on the
weekend and we have our own Discord and
and people people will come come play
chess for
um two or three hours and we've actually
had
um uh people uh there's a lady who's
over over 80 years old who grew up
playing chess in Soviet Russia and she
plays with us so there's that other guy
who played chess in prison and up in San
Quentin and he's out of prison now and
he comes and play and brings prison
chests to to the Virginia green on the
weekends and so that's a lot of fun too
um so good characters all around and
I've been meeting a lot of great people
here in San Francisco playing chess so
many cool stories until finally I want
to ask you who is the big chess hero for
the chess Community here in the Bay Area
um I would say uh
Elliot Winslow um from the um as an I am
um in Tuesday night marathons and he um
he's done a great job annotating all of
our classical games and and so big shout
out shout out to him for all of his his
work that he does
um putting together
um and annotating all the games that we
get we play every week at the Mechanics
Institute on Tuesdays so shout out to
him awesome thanks a lot too chest fever
is on in San Francisco
definitely seems like San Francisco is
the place to be to play some interesting
chess I love the stories from Drew there
Gathering a bunch of people even 80
years olds people have been to prison to
play chess what a great game it is just
Gathering people all around the world
breaks boundaries and uh meanwhile
Magnus Carlson well we were chatting
that well Tanya was chatting he's been
thinking the whole time wow four minute
thinking I really like this night
Retreat I've got to say Ivanka from
anishkiri
um do you think Magnus was feeling the
pressure
yeah he's certainly uh anticipating war
and ish is going to be doing next
because that night has a purpose you
know it's going to Spring over to the
afro-born and start prodding at some
weak pawns there on E6 and also there's
light squares and wow Magnus reacts with
that in a very direct way he says well
you cannot put your knight there and I'm
prepared to weaken my king and I think
this is quite a sensible Choice actually
because after all White's pieces are all
on the back row so they're not going to
attack the black king that easily so wow
I'm impressed yeah I'm very impressed
too I think Magnus had to choose this
because as you say if he'd taken a time
out maybe improve the White Queen then
sooner or later the Black Knight is just
going to Leap Forward and the White
Knight sorry yeah and uh
I mean there's ideas of attacking the
queen this Pawn is eternally weak this
Outpost in the center you could plant
one night here you could maybe later on
plant the other night there as well just
occupy this Square now it's more
difficult for Anish to kind of find the
ideal squares for his pieces this pump
push does also hint that you can
threaten to kick away this Knight over
the next few moves so I'm wondering
whether Anish will stop this idea
ideally you want to maybe Retreat the
White Knight and reroute it again back
into the center this is the dream
destination for one of the two white
Knights this is The Outpost that can
never ever be challenged but uh the
problem is you do have to calculate for
example a pawn being pushed and now
maybe this Pawn in the center will be
lost after the White Knight has to move
uh also there are ideas for example
again of the queen Coming forward some
pressure on this Pawn so I'm just
wondering does a niche take a time out
here just to push upon to stop black
from advancing any further
feels a bit a bit slow somehow it's it's
kind of a reluctant move if you play it
now you don't really want to be reacting
you want to be the one initiating so uh
what can white play it crossed my mind
as well to push this point it looks too
weakening a bit too maybe it's possible
I I must admit David I was thinking well
if black can weaken the king why can't
why it's I'm going to push the Knight
back yeah kick this Knight away as soon
as this night Retreats at least there's
less pressure on your Central Pawn so
you're more flexible and uh the White
Knight which we said was lacking a clear
route into the center at least you have
a nice home for it you don't really
weaken your king in a way because yes
you've pushed forward with your Pawn but
you've got three great defensive pieces
around the white king and it's the black
king which is lacking Defenders yeah no
uh the more I'm I'm looking at it the
more I'm thinking that this is the move
that anise should play yeah direct
action I agree and uh later on you can
kind of hint so that you'll start
chipping away eroding blacks Pawn chain
on this side if the black balls
disappear Black's King is just
completely open it's uh yeah yeah it
looks very logical actually the more I
look at it but it does take a bit of
Courage it's it's not a typical kind of
everyday maneuver just pushing your Pawn
forward it's something that we saw on
day one of this tournament with Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so where they both
pushed these pawns and for a moment it
was risky for both sides but uh yeah
right now it looks very
logical for a niche I don't think he
should waste time with any kind of
cautious preventative measures I think
it's time to take action now
I agree David now's time for
active measures it's not time to be
waiting around and
okay he does wait however he drops his
Knight back this makes a lot of sense
long term strategically you want to
reroute your night but allow the serious
pressure against this Pawn in the middle
now maybe the moment has passed as soon
as the black queen comes forward
there's a three piece attack on this
point it's defended three times as well
but it does mean that the white pieces
are tied down
to the defense you can never really step
into the ideal Central Square with white
either because this Pawn would just drop
so you can't find the root in yeah
I do feel Magnus will just automatically
make that queen move because it's what
every French player is taught you know
you put the pressure on White's weak
point you fighter White's activity with
activity in return yeah and Magnus will
put some pressure on this pawn it does
feel like a knee she's playing it safe
but he's in a must win situation
remember and uh okay Magnus doesn't play
it safe okay okay Magnus is the one
taking risks suddenly instead of
bringing the queen to a very nice
defective uh defensive and active Square
uh sorry he pushes this Pawn forward
kicking the White Knight into the square
it wanted to use anyway
okay I mentioned that this is tempting
for black because you can win white
Central Pawn but suddenly Black's King
is very very open suddenly Black's pawns
start to fall as well and uh yeah I'm
worried here for magnus's King Knight
takes Pawn would be a threat
okay Anish it feels like he's been given
another second opportunity to get active
and uh right now this is the position I
don't think you have time to take this
Pawn simply this pawn and this Pawn uh
these two weaknesses in front of the
black king
they're up for grabs immediately you
have to be really careful there all
right drama Anish Gary he has to win
this game do you think he will after
that move maybe
um if Magnus is forced to just trade off
white Central Knight then that white
knight is replaced by White's rook and
white pieces are suddenly pouring
forward
I mean I said this was on the cards for
black but I think you needed to prepare
it first yeah it feels like Magnus just
jumped the gun slightly I I agree with
you there David I'm I'm surprised
actually wasn't a move I suspected
especially when Magnus just needs to
draw to secure the match why play in
such a risky fashion and there you go he
captures the Knight is just too
dangerous to allow the White Knight to
capture the pawn and now I'm just
expecting Rook takes Knight unless
there's some tactical Ploy but there
isn't yeah you definitely want to take
with a piece on this Central Square
regain this Black Knight with a piece if
you take with the white porn yes you
solve the problem of your isolated porn
but suddenly the white pieces will be
blocked white Rooks White's Queen I
think you need to maintain this Outpost
take with a piece unless we're missing
something like you say it has to be
tactical strategically you take back
this night instantly with the white Rook
I mean you want to maintain control over
that square
and you'll block up your own major
pieces no and uh it's also the way to
fight against a weak Pawn the the pawn
on E6 that's a backward Pawn that is a
sitting Target so you want to make sure
you control the square in front of it
with a piece it's kind of like this
nimsovich saying which is like control
your restrain you destroy yeah and we
like our brutal terms in chess yeah and
it's just so logical to take with the
rook and she's okay he's got a lot of
time on the clock but he spent a minute
on maybe the most obvious recapture
um I mean this one is automatic in Blitz
if you give this uh this position to a
niche he'll play Rook takes Knight
instantly one second uh I think if you
give it to him in a bullet game he'll
play Rook takes Knight instantly
yeah I think he just he's not trusting
his instincts maybe it's because his
confidence is a bit low after losing two
games today already he's second guessing
himself and he could save this one
nearly two minutes now you could save
that for later
yeah for sure it's so surprising White's
Rook can get active take that Knight off
the board
I agree I understand
I also don't understand either I mean
I'm just looking at the computer
assessments Rook takes night that's a
no-brainer porn takes night
you're just gonna go back into equal
territory so don't do that but why is a
niche thinking over two minutes he's
just Frozen and he's giving Magnus more
time to think Magnus was actually in a
bit of time trouble already Magnus has a
lot of weaknesses to deal with but a
niche by stopping for two and a half
minutes
he's really boosting uh magnus's chances
of holding this position let's jump in
to explain why we're so confused why
we're so shocked right now uh black has
just captured a knight on this square
and it's automatic you just take with a
rook later this Square can act as a
launching pad either for white Rook
White's Queen White's Knight you want to
save this Outpost in front of a backward
isolated Pawn uh you want to save it for
later this square if you take with the
white Pawn yes you've solved the issue
of your weakness on D4 but look at
White's Rook it's just blocked by its
own Pawn look away it's queen of Rook
they're just staring at a well fortified
pawn and he does what he takes a pawn it
makes no logical sense the only thing I
can justify this Pawn capture with is
maybe long term he wants to use his
Knight on the Square but Black's
covering that square with his own Knight
look at Black's pieces suddenly they're
pouring forward
this was not possible black Bishop is
now active but this was not possible if
White had taken with his Rook the black
Bishop is eternally tied down to the
defense of this weak Pawn
anishagiri he's broken all the
traditional rules we talk about there
you mentioned nimsovich Ivanka who wrote
a great book who kind of formed modern
positionable chess understanding and
he's gone against all of that Knight
takes Knight Pawn takes yes he wants to
get his Knight in but after this bishop
move
he pushed his ball forward what is this
Knight doing
suddenly if it ever moves if it moves to
either of these two squares the black
Bishop which is the worst piece on the
board would just trade itself off for
the White Knight happily and black is
left with a nice piece left five yeah
now Magnus is trading off Queens he's
going for towards the end game
it's just all gone wrong for Anish
he's just I don't like this is one of
the most bemusing confusing decisions
I've ever seen I must admit just in
terms of strategy the top players
they're also good at that part of the
game normally now if the Queens
disappear look at Black's pieces Black's
Rook is ready to enter the position
Black's night you can never ever get rid
of it white pieces are just passive and
uh black has a protective past Pawn
let's not forget that true in the end
game this is going to be a monster
you've just let it run early it was
blocked
yeah
it just seems to be the Magnus effect
like Anish somehow doesn't seem to
be just
playing in his in the way that we know
that he can play
and it's unsurprising I mean just take a
look at Black's pieces they've just
launched themselves forward The Rook is
on its perfect line I mean there's like
a sacrifice bring
on the F2 Square oh and just the fact
that the evaluation bar has shot up
means that black has a winning move and
that can't be to do with just retreating
your Bishop anisha's just attacked this
bishop if you step it back probably
black is still doing great still with an
active uh Rook on this second line but I
mean just the fact that the evaluation
bar shot up oh wow okay black has not
just one winning move that's the big
shock black has three winning moves at
least maybe even more and it's all to do
with moving this Black Knight out of the
way the best move is apparently to
sacrifice this night for a pawn even if
you just Retreat this Black Knight the
second best move you are winning uh you
can also give it up on a different
square but the whole idea is that you're
crashing through remember the last game
Magnus he crashed through on anisha's F7
Square anisha's F7 Square as black in
the previous game what's the weakness
now he's had two squares the weakness
lightning has struck twice and Magnus
finds the best move of course he does he
doesn't even Retreat his Knight he
doesn't keep it safe he gives up his
night for the pawn and the whole idea is
if the Knight is captured disaster Rook
takes Pawn
capitulation on the second rank
breakthrough and Checkmate is coming
yeah the white Bishop alone cannot hold
the fort if the white Bishop Retreats
The Black Queen just slides across and
she's going to join her two Rooks and
this poor King is just completely cut
off on the first round look at Black's
Rooks the power of them
and look at White's works I mean look at
the White's pieces all on the back row
um wow this is
our Niche is going to be so disappointed
it turns so quickly you had a dominant
position with a natural move computer
gave nearly plus one for white
three four moves later it says black is
winning and uh you're getting checkmated
so that's why you've got to follow
strategy you can't break the rules you
can't just freestyle can't just make
things up as you go along
because you will get punished especially
especially against someone like Magnus
and he still has five and a half minutes
on his clock it's
[Music]
in a row
wow three nil yesterday three nil today
yeah yeah I also love one game three on
the day before that but it feels like in
this one that maybe wasn't necessarily
magnus's amazing play it just feels like
a niche just imploded it all went wrong
with him he kind of somehow just had a
very bad day at the office but this is
the thing so Anish he's a great opening
specialist we know he's released several
very successful chessboard courses uh
kind of he's taught this new generation
how to play the opening and
promise he doesn't focus on the rest of
his game as much the top players they
play lots of Blitz they kind of solve
lots of endgame studies they work on end
games and Anish he's good at that stuff
of course but game one today he had a
winning advantage against Magnus in the
opening a few minutes later he was lost
game two he had a slight Advantage as
black in the opening a few minutes later
he was lost here he had a clear
Advantage with white in the opening five
minutes later he's dead lost it's like
it's clear what the weakness is
um I mean I've been I've had patents in
my own career where I'm losing lots of
games in the same way every time it's
always the middle game always certain
types of positions always certain type
of attacking opponents and you have to
work on these things you can't just
study the opening and say okay I'll
survive the opening I'll have an
advantage out the opening it's not
enough you need more I can understand
the Temptation or just working on what
you're really good at exactly and then
I'll save the middle name for later well
someone described that kind of strategy
to me as a developing a claw you know
you have a big claw that you just thump
your opponents with you know that could
be your opening could be your end game
it could be your grinding
[Laughter]
and uh then you know and and you work on
this and so you become the best in the
world so that's one strategy but as
David says it does leave you open up to
other other aspects of the game and here
I suspect my my explanation for why
things turned out this way for Anish is
because he wanted to win so much he
really wanted to give Magnus a big fight
and if you look at a lot of his errors
in these last three games they've been
forced errors you know he's been by
forced errors I mean that he's been
playing forcing moves he's been very
direct he's been forcing Magnus to put
to fight in a certain way and that just
hasn't worked out
yeah and in a way Magnus has sussed him
out Anish magnus's score against the
niche in recent years is just huge uh so
he knows anisha's psychological uh
weaknesses he knows his Tendencies his
preferences and remember at the top
level they've used that word themselves
in interviews Universal you have to be
able to play all types of positions all
types of openings and all types of uh
make all types of decisions according to
the one moment but Anish he's trying to
follow this template uh this of success
which just doesn't work against the
likes of Magnus it works against 99.9 of
chess players but uh at the very top
level
yeah it's just uh I think that's one
area of his game if I were his coach at
least I would say okay yes you're great
in the opening you don't need to work on
that anymore you've mastered it just to
work on kind of middle game decision
strategic decisions playing on the front
foot putting these players under
long-term pressure not just forcing them
to find good moves like you said
anisha's forced Mac just to find these
good moves it's not as if he made it
difficult uh it's not as if he said okay
you've got a narrow path you have find
and only move to survive no Magnus had
plenty of winning opportunities as we
saw in that last in that last turn yeah
yeah and there you can see the look on
anisha's face as he contemplates his
position and wonders how can he survive
he cannot survive this position his it's
and tatters
yeah and uh oh I feel harsh but I was
gonna maybe show let's bring up the
analysis board just while Anish Ponders
whether to resign or not but I was going
to show just the end game of the last
battle between these two so this was the
final position of game two if you
remember uh he resigned here because
White's Rooks are crashing in on this F7
square and now let's flick through to
the current position and he's about to
resign now because blacks Rooks are
coming in uh sorry to crash through on
the F2 Square so it's it's basically the
same pattern yes this is more
complicated with more pieces on the
board uh more complicated middle game
but it's the same pattern it's just the
same weakness uh just with colors
reversed so Magnus has pinpointed yeah
the we spot in the enemy camp and he's
about to crash through the problem is
you can't defend this Pawn there's
literally no way to defend it and you
have a choice of two pieces to take this
bishop or this Knight but no matter
which piece
where it takes pawn and yeah you can
never allow two Rooks to form a battery
like this along the second rank they're
targeting the bishop the bishop has no
safe squares
and uh it's going to be Checkmate any
moment and
let's go back to Anish it looks like he
put his hand on his Mouse he's about to
make a move or is he about to click the
resign button because it is that
hopeless
I think we're gonna have to use Simon's
tagline just resign now I mean the
problem is okay he takes the bishop
but we're fully expecting Magnus to pick
up his Rook on f8 and capture the pawn
on F2 and just ask her
the question to Anish what are you going
to do about your Bishop
Magnus uh leaning forward he looks like
he was getting ready to uh to celebrate
this Victory and each down at 30 seconds
as well he throws his Knight in the way
but this won't save the day this night
can be captured by the black Rooks it
can even be captured by Black's Knight I
think
um
yeah I mean you're giving up material
here if anything so black will be up on
material and attacking
plus 21. yeah looks like it's going to
be a short day again for well both of
them Magnus Carl's not about to win game
three out of three against Anish Geary
struggling here really today and also
yesterday he is the king of Twitter
though and he is great at selfies we are
asking you guys to share chess pictures
and chess selfies how are you watching
the show who are you watching with maybe
you are together with some friends maybe
you are at school maybe you're at work
what are you doing we want to see how
you guys are following the chess so
please share using chess Champs on
Twitter and if you're watching from
school please do it during your break
time
okay we don't need to get into trouble
chess is never trouble this is always a
good idea I saw a very cool picture this
morning on Twitter where someone was at
a concert and the person in front of
them was playing
[Laughter]
feeling they didn't spend their own
money on tickets for
and that we see the root capture the
night yeah this is the safe approach I
was expecting Magnus to go for something
a bit more flashy at least now one of
the Rooks can be removed from the board
so there won't be that immediately that
immediate breakthrough against the white
king okay anisha's kind of tricked
Magnus uh in a small way that was very
clever by Anish to survive but the
problem is you're not surviving for long
now rather than the second rank
breakthrough it's going to be the first
rank uh Black's Rook challenging White's
Rook you cannot take now you cannot
trade off those Rooks because Black's
Queen would swoop down recapture and
that would end in Checkmate on rank one
so uh okay everything disappears and at
the very end Black's gonna be a few
pawns up yeah he's so clinical he's not
giving a niche a single chance and
bearing in mind that Anish is in a
must-win situation he's just put that
nail in the coffin
yeah we will see everything get
exchanged the Queens are about to
disappear Magnus will emerge three pawns
ahead and Anish throws in the towel and
resigns and Shake three wins for Magnus
and it's over he wins the match horrible
day for Anish giri in San Francisco but
Magnus Carlsen is on fire his seventh
win in a row with a performance rating
way above 3000